Let's check our understanding
of N-module redundancy.
Suppose we have a computer and we want
to tolerate faults that can occur there.
So we go to store and buy two more
computers just like the first one and
put all of them on the same desk.
And our approach to redundancy
is that we run every computation
on all three computers,
we compare their outputs, and
we take that output on which two or
all three agree.
And with this approach we think
we can tolerate any single event
of the following kinds.
Check each of those
that can be tolerated.
Can we tolerate any single alpha
particle strike in a processor?
Can we tolerate any
single building collapse?
Can we tolerate any single earthquake?
And can we tolerate any mistake
in single processor design?